>> Automated: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So,
good afternoon everyone,
and welcome to the African
and Middle East division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, chief of
the division, and I'm delighted
to see you, so many of you
here today for the presentation
that will surely, surely thrill you.
It is by Toyin Falola, a man who,
in his writings and in his talks,
challenges our preconceptions,
who let's us look at the world,
and at Africa in particular, from
new and exciting perspective.
Dr. Angel Batiste will introduce
him more fully in a moment,
but I feel I must first
say a few things about him.
I actually met him here at
the library several years ago
when he first became a member of
the board of the Scholars Council
at the Kluge Center,
which at the time was
under Dr. Carolyn Brown,
who is with us today.
And so we had a couple of
very interesting discussions,
and then one day, a couple of years
later, he called out of the blue
and suggested that I
present my candidacy
to the African Studies
Association Board, as I had worked
for many years on North Africa.
I did, and was very
honored when I was elected
by the members of the ASC, ASC.
I then attended two of the
board's weekend meetings
and watched how Professor
Falola deftly
and diplomatically
guided his proceedings,
highlighted important issues,
advised on important matters,
suggest the speakers,
brought up new ideas.
Why am I saying this?
My point is that he is an -- not
only an extraordinary scholar,
as you will hear in a moment,
but that his accomplishment range
in many, many fields, in many ways.
He's a dreamer, a scholar,
a thinker,
but he's also very man
-- a practical man.
A man who knows where
things should be going.
And so, not surprisingly, as
you will be invited to see in,
after the talk, Dr. Batiste has
arranged a wonderful display
of Professor Falola's
works and works
about him in our conference room.
So, not surprisingly, I found a
book which was dedicated to him,
and the book speaks about
the man, the boss, the muse.
But if you look at the chapters,
Toyin Falola, a poet within
and without, chapter three, chapter
four, Toyin Falola, volcanic force,
[inaudible] news, Toyin Falola,
the African historian and scholar,
Toyin Falola, the master teacher,
Toyin Falola in his
intellectual majesty,
Toyin Falola, a new Renaissance man.
And it goes on chapter after
chapter, the recognition
of what he has contributed
to the field.
So, but I will leave that
to Dr. Batiste, who told me,
"Don't take my ideas this morning."
No. I said, "No, no.
There's so much to be said."
But I want to say a few things
about our division before we
continue with the program.
Our division is very honored to have
Professor Falola speak to us today.
But it's a division that is
responsible for countries
around the world, for 78
countries, to be exact.
And for its literature,
politics, history, humanity,
social sciences, sciences.
We have collections that we hold
[inaudible] in the vernacular,
collections from the Middle East,
Central Asia, the whole of Africa,
North and South Saharan,
the Caucasus.
We go -- we extend up to small
groups in China and we have --
and we have three sections, and
three sections with scholars,
really, who are working and
who advise and help researchers
to bring their materials to them.
The three sections are the Hebraic
section, the African section,
and the Near East sections.
And today, this program is
organized by the African section.
And we don't only, you know,
provide the materials for research.
We also try to display our
materials to attract people.
We have exhibits.
We have certainly exciting
programs, as the one today.
We show films.
And recently, after a
long administrative road
that we all took, we're now on the
social media and we have blogs,
and our staff writes blogs about the
collections, about our materials.
We actually have Facebook.
Finally, we moved into
the 21st century.
And so but they focus,
again, on our collections,
as a way of reaching out.
So, you will have, on your
chair, you will find our ads
for our blogs and Facebooks.
So, those, we announce
our programs there.
Please subscribe so that you can
have the announcements come to you
and you know what is going
on here at the Library.
We have -- like us on Facebook.
We're really nice.
You know, you should
just like us, okay?
And I have, again, yesterday,
African Studies Association has
decided link up to us, and they --
not only do they like us.
They actually posted
[inaudible] blog on [inaudible].
They announced Professor
Falola's talk, so that is going
out to the African Studies community
all over, and so we're very excited
about that and we'd
like you to join us.
I will stop now, but
I want to remind you
that we are videotaping this
program, as we videotape most
of our programs, which means that
it will be accessible not only here,
the talk, but around the world.
And so, if when the
question-answer time comes,
if you want to ask
questions, please remember
that you are being videotaped,
and asking questions means
that you've given us
permission to record you
and that your remarks
may be posted on the web.
Okay? So, now, let me introduce
our own Dr. Angel Batiste,
area specialist for West Africa
and, really, a [inaudible] scholar
and librarian in the African
section of the division.
And she will give you more.
More depth to my presentation
on Professor Falola.
Okay, so Dr. Batiste.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Angel Batiste:
Good afternoon.
I'd like to echo Dr. Deeb, the chief
of our division, in welcoming you
to the African and
Middle Eastern Division.
And I'd also like to extend
a personal invitation.
Return, return to our African and
Middle Eastern Division reading room
to explore the vast wealth
of Africana resources
that are held by the library.
Today is a special honor for me.
Dr. Falola doesn't quite know it,
but this has been an objective
of mine for probably
five or more years,
so I thank you for being here today.
It is a special honor for me to
introduce Professor Toyin Falola,
widely acclaimed by
colleagues and students
in the African studies field,
as the dean of Nigerian history,
the doyen of African studies,
and a Neo-Renaissance man.
Dr. Falola is the Jacob and
Francis singer, most sacred chair
in the humanities, and university
distinguished teaching professor
of African studies at the
University of Texas at Austin.
He is a member of the Library
of Congress Scholars Council,
and currently he is in residence
as the Kluge chair in countries
and cultures of the south, at the
library's John W. Kluge Center.
Researching our project titled
African Immigrant Communities
in the United States.
A historian, a poet, critic, master
teacher, and community leader,
Dr. Falola earned his
BA and PhD, in history,
at the University of Ife in Nigeria.
He is a fellow of the
Historical Society of Nigeria,
and a fellow of the
Nigerian Academy of Letters.
His wide-ranging intellectual
interests include Atlantic history,
diaspora and migration, empire and
globalization, intellectual history,
international relations,
religion and culture.
Dr. Falola has more
than 150 books in print.
Actually, I did a search of
the library's card catalog,
and we hold 156 books in print.
As a champion of the African studies
[inaudible] Dr. Falola has supported
research through his
mentorship of students,
and his long term editorship of the
African Economic History Review.
His service on many academic journal
editorial boards and his creation
and editorship of several
academic book series,
including the University
of Rochester series,
studies in African
History and the Diaspora,
the Carolina Academic Press,
African Rural series, and Culture
and Customs of Africa
by Greenwood Press.
Dr. Falola has received various
awards and honors, including,
I believe, five honorary
doctorate degrees,
seven honorary doctorate
degrees, the Jean Holloway award
for teaching excellence, the
Texas Execs teaching award,
the Khaldun Distinguished
Award for Research Excellence,
the Cheikh Anta Diop Award
for Exemplary Scholarship
in African Studies, and the African
Studies Association Distinguished
Africanist Award.
The Association of Third World
Studies has endowed a book prize
names after him, the
Toyin Falola annual prize
for the best book on Africa.
The cumulative contributions of
Dr. Falola, as an imminent scholar
and public intellectual, have
led to five volumes published
in his honor, in a biocritical work.
The impact of his scholarship
is presented
in Abdul Bangura's Toyin Falola
and African Epistemologies.
I'd now like to introduce
Dr. Toyin Falola.
[ Applause ]
>> Toyin Falola: Thank you.
I think those introductions
should serve as a lecture
so that we can begin
to ask questions.
Thank you so much for your kindness
and I can only pray and wish
that I'm able to repay
that kindness.
I have to follow sudden
combinations,
some of which may be new to you,
which is that, any time I speak,
I must first exchange a
greetings from the kings
that I do represent each time
I do a public performance.
And I'm representing
three kings here.
First I must extend my greetings
to you [inaudible] who ask me
to extend this greetings to you.
I have to deliver those messages.
I'm very grateful to Mary,
to Angel, to Carolyn here.
You wanted to come on -- she
wanted to come and do her research
and [inaudible] decided to stay.
When she was a director of Kluge,
she asked me for a proposal,
which I wrote on the
basis of which I'm here.
And on December 15th, I
will be doing a conference
on African immigrant in the US.
This is more publicity, and
I hope you all will come.
Let me provide a small
context to this topic,
and it's a [inaudible] context.
Many of you may not be aware
that this is a tremendous moment
in Africa, with the creation of
so many private universities.
Indeed, in a country like Nigeria,
the number of private
universities is now more
than the number of public schools.
And we have colleagues
who have the universities
of their own [inaudible] call
to me [inaudible] call to me,
I will have been thinking of
establishing my own university.
Because nobody saw this 30
years ago, where a colleague
in Seattle moved to Ghana to
establish his own university.
And a good friend of mine,
when I was teaching [inaudible]
to establish his own university.
What this has done is to let us
begin to rethink the inheritances
in various ways, and to use those
private universities to test a set
of new ideas and to see
things that don't walk.
With private universities, can
rethink with [inaudible] outside
of a [inaudible] state power
structure and outside of corruption.
So, and as we are -- I'm
on the board of them,
some of these universities, in which
we have the opportunities to say,
"This is how we want to define
humanities," and things like that,
"and this is how we want to
define some of what we inherited
from the western academy and
localize them, far more creatively
than our predecessors have done."
And this is part of the challenge.
And what I've been
doing, in recent years,
is to rethink many of these things.
So, this lecture will actually
work more as a workshop
than as a lecture, and which has
been three days since [inaudible].
Here's what we agree with.
How do we now translate
what we're talking
about into curriculum
and begin to teach them?
Because our project of
translation moves us away just
from making sure it's
[inaudible] without grounding them
in those things that are practical.
And we're very grateful
to the [inaudible]
that that whole date is award for
last year to one of these person
who created his own
university in Ghana.
He used to work for Microsoft,
and the ability to overthink many
of this is all new in the continent.
So, the component of what I want
to present is in four categories.
What is [inaudible] archive?
How can I break it down
into its components?
I will do those.
But the real challenge you want,
the ontologies, epistemologies,
I will not be able to do.
Because that's, will
fit more into --
morph into a seminar of three hours
where we can actually
do a lot of debate.
And I will also do how we can
connect these [inaudible] archives
into the public domain.
So, the component I'll be talking
about explains the interest
in library and librarians, and
then I will leave out the component
that will interest those
who like to do [inaudible].
So, let me start by defining what
I mean by [inaudible] archives,
which is how you cumulate awards
and test and ideas and symbols
and shrines and images,
performances, and [inaudible]
that document, as well as picture
religious experiences and practices,
in ways in which we have [inaudible]
has turned an Africa world
[inaudible] of philosophies,
literatures,
languages, histories, and more.
And by implication, these
[inaudible] archives are huge,
unbounded in scale and scope.
They store a tremendous
amount of data on both natural
and supernatural agents
[inaudible] gods, good,
witches, life, death, festivals.
The interaction between the
spiritual spaces, you and I,
things you can see, and
things you cannot see.
And we like this change.
These archives constitute and
save knowledge about the visible
and invisible world, even
including what you are going
to call the nonworld.
Together with forces that breathe
and forces that don't breathe,
secular ideas and nonsecular ones,
with destinies, ideas within cities,
kinships, medicine, to viral
meds, sciences and technologies.
Above all, the content shelves
on sacrifices and shrines, names,
places, incantations,
invocations, and the entire cosmos
of all the [inaudible]
and their living subjects,
among human and nonhuman species.
[Inaudible] might have talk about
no more than [inaudible], nonhumans,
and humans, because in ritual
knowledge, they do not make
that distinctions between
nonhuman and humans.
They combine them.
And in some ways, what is on down
at your feet, what is in the sky,
things in the, in the deep
sea, they are combined
as part of a knowledge system.
And I'm [inaudible] the term
archives in relation to rituals
to challenge the conventions
of western archives.
Namely, what is deemed worthy
of preservation and organization
as data, whether or not it is
interpreted at any given moment?
And this intervention is not
to restrict archives
inside the location
of the library or university
or museum.
Because you can just
locate them that way,
the way we traditionally think,
in terms of western
archives and library.
And I'm also seeking to apply
the techniques and resources
of academic archives to rituals, so
that we can have greater evaluation
and greater preservation.
And I have [inaudible] good
sense of archive, as well.
One that does not require
residency in the academy.
And I'm insisting that we must
never lose sight of that dimension
of archive, that is never fully
collected [inaudible] our intense
power and agency in invisible ways.
The Library of Congress who
deal with the visible ways,
but there are also archives
that had invisible ways to them,
and I provoke a category
of archive itself
with the revolutionary insistence
[inaudible] of ritual as a name
for a light component of
cultural meaning making.
How do we contend with the
destruction of archive?
Various forms of violence.
Can we qualify, with
certainty, what we can't explain?
In varied ways, a countless number
of [inaudible] priests, devotees,
and practitioners created oral and
visual libraries, which are linked
to ritual complexes and
secular [inaudible].
Subsequently, cultural
knowledge has extended
from the deep past
to our present day.
It is true there knowledge
that histories
and traditions were constituted
while identities were formed.
And philosophy, as
we know it, emerged.
Although a lot of people were part
of the community, they were there
as ordinary members, while
others constituted leadership.
Today, without specific names,
we live out the [inaudible]
collectively as it passed.
And as traditions, sometimes using
traditions in a very misleading way.
And there's a [inaudible] of what
to call the traditions
and ritual archives.
We provide templates for
the future, and the contents
of these archives become
philosophy, literature, and history.
They are interpretations
manifested in our present,
as part of our engagement
with [inaudible].
Just as in poems, ritual dances,
sacred drums, ritual textiles,
components of the archives
can be isolated,
but they can also be combined
into a body of interlocking ideas
and philosophy, and the
context of rough terrain
of what you can call
ancestral knowledge.
Whether you aggregate
or disaggregate them,
they are called memory,
and remembrance
in various ways and forms.
They star most of our
indigenous production.
Memories, legacies, histories
of our lives and ancestors,
and they lead us to the reinvention
of the cosmos that we inhabit.
Different from, but not useless,
to what modern science does.
Why postulating the
[inaudible] of archives?
That is, archives resulting from
the [inaudible] countdown built
on a template of western knowledge.
We can deduce that the
[inaudible] well, in some number
of ways [inaudible] it has not
only proven to be severely limited,
but in terms of [inaudible]
possibilities as well as [inaudible]
but it's also an agency of control
that frames our subjectivities
and objectivities and
that we can pursue them.
The [inaudible] archival name
pose on us and given prominence
over the ancestral ritual
archive, living to the original
and the traditional of
indigenous perspective.
They are not genius.
In fact, nothing reveals
the shallowness
of the [inaudible] archive,
more than the very timeframe
its contents I were to cover.
[Inaudible] national archives
in Ghana [inaudible] Nigeria,
there is [inaudible] records
[inaudible] as expected,
straight to no more than 65
years, any archive in Africa.
They only cover 65 years, and we are
talking of a century before Christ.
Contributions in those
[inaudible] archives are crowded
within the colonial time era,
and after the colonization,
many of them have been
left to their own devises,
as post-colonial leaders
struggle for some other things.
And as to the time before, only
the long 19th century [inaudible].
Regarding the post-colonial era is a
[inaudible] knowledge [inaudible] be
confined to the media, because the
archives stop collecting materials
from the 60s.
Why was trouble for
[inaudible] economic [inaudible]
and cultural survival.
Histories of centuries
between the Stone Age
and the 10th century have
been either left to rot
or are easily ignored, and in the
process, lost, for the most part.
This loss is a function of
lost archives, and suddenly,
there is regard for those archives
that can still be reclaimed,
as in the case of ritual archives.
They are there.
We just have to reclaim them.
The [inaudible] that the
past was not possible
to recover is [inaudible]
or assumption
that many people have
come to accept,
simply because of [inaudible]
coloniality of knowledge, which,
unfortunately, incapacitated
the possibility of use
and transformation of
our collective memories.
The very incapacitation of
ritual archives is, by itself,
an example of an epistemic violence.
Before going to archives [inaudible]
while not necessarily complementary,
have created a knowledge divide.
The [inaudible] one that is aligned
to power [inaudible] and the ritual
that is outlined with
[inaudible] as opposed
to [inaudible] ritual
[inaudible] the colonial
as raw materials [inaudible]
existing permanently
in its shadows and dominance.
Indeed, the archives of
coloniality [inaudible]
that go a long way toward advancing
the projects of [inaudible] concepts
and legacies to save
[inaudible] interest.
Ritual archives, on the other
hand, deal with ancestral legacies
and indigenous concepts
and epistemologies.
History, as defined in
the colonial archives,
is different from [inaudible]
to use [inaudible] by example,
as defined in the [inaudible]
archives.
They are not doing the same thing.
While [inaudible] ritual
archives [inaudible]
within the realm of
[inaudible] academy.
Analysis of colonial archives
I assessed in the categories
of originality and validity
in the same academy.
In the western conception
of historical knowledge
[inaudible] just to stay
with one example, lacks validity.
While academic history
is [inaudible] with one,
time is unreliable, but history is.
If time is not accessible and
transparent, why history is?
[Inaudible] what is [inaudible]
graphic knowledge in ways
that western conception
of knowledge can never do.
As an assessment of western
education [inaudible] successful
acquires new [inaudible]
of knowledge for mobility.
[Inaudible] rationalizing
the pre-western,
what grudgingly [inaudible]
world views.
Why distancing themselves from the
previous [inaudible] knowledge.
[Inaudible] historical knowledge
system has been [inaudible] very
formal western system invested with
colonizing values of [inaudible].
What is -- how do we define
and isolate the contents
of these archives and
their meanings?
You can do it in multiple ways.
You can invoke [inaudible]
in literature,
ritual performances
[inaudible] representation
of gods and goddesses.
It's a fact that this enter
the realm of routine expression
of spirituality, proverbs,
songs, poetry,
all of which generate meanings of
religious and secular significance.
Second, we can utilize the
opportunity to frame some dimensions
of the epistemology [inaudible]
significance of these archives,
which is in fact a body of knowledge
on a wide range of issues, including
but not limited to
cultural recognition,
ideas and idea formation,
semiotics and education.
And I'm going to suggest
some transformational ways
to keep these archives.
I want to revalidate these
archives, but in doing so,
within western [inaudible]
academies,
to invoke indigenous
practitioners in research
and knowledge dissemination and
to formulate evaluation mechanisms
to authenticate indigenous
knowledge.
And those will communicate
them using the [inaudible]
of the educational system,
indigenous ways of knowing,
along with the knowledge
on the centers
of those [inaudible]
knowledges was fully blended
with what we do in the academy.
Ritual archives tell us that
we must review our question,
our externally derived
approaches, and the limitations
of the methodologies with the pride.
Western derived disciplines, such
as religious [inaudible], history,
philosophy, and subjects
of the humanities,
have carefully fragmented
ritual archives.
But it's time for all those
disciplines to combine
to provide [inaudible] of the
center of indigenous epistemologies.
To unify the anthologies
and combine them to theories
that will be treated as universal.
To take an example, if our
ritual archives can work,
definition [inaudible] by example.
We can call it discipline
[inaudible]
and turn it into a department.
It's [inaudible] the scholars to
learn and work across disciplines,
and they probably will have been
able to decode this epistemology
by now, and use it to create
other forms of knowledge.
They will have covered [inaudible]
dimensions of the indigenous.
As scholars dealing with
Africa, questions must be posed
as to how each of us understands
and applies indigenous knowledge,
which will [inaudible]
values and cultures
in the research I'm teaching.
Should we always ground the analysis
and understanding of our fields,
solely in western derived
epistemologies?
No, we should not be doing this.
Indeed, where we started,
practitioners and others
who create archives for us.
Others have not studied
us, and suddenly,
we are [inaudible] studied assets.
So, we have to engage in
various layers of conversation.
Conversations with ourselves,
conversations with ritual archives
in order to [inaudible]
the voices that are not --
that are delegitimated
in academic spaces.
Pointing to the contents of
these archives as [inaudible]
of multiple epistemology [inaudible]
as well as [inaudible] messaging.
How we must interrogate
broad academic concepts.
What are these things?
I will only use just
one example object
so that I can bring home what
I'm talking about, just objects.
Objects are tests, and you
will look at me very closely.
I'm a body of these
objects and it's deliberate,
because the body you are
looking at is just part
of the objects [inaudible] archive,
including [inaudible],
because it has meaning.
If I do it this way,
this way, this way,
with respect to the way I turn it,
is an object that is
communicating messages.
Gods and goddesses generate around
them a wide range of paraphernalia
of test and sounds
[inaudible] sounds, visible
and invisible symbols
[inaudible] symbols.
Objects and signs.
Orality, in itself, is extensive,
comprising parables, proverbs,
tales, allegories, dilemma stories.
Drums are musical compositions
go with venerations,
along with sacrifices, and
practitioners and priests
within [inaudible] and [inaudible].
Rituals are ritual speech.
Ritual speech is very elaborate.
Connect with [inaudible] and
indigenous proverb systems,
and it talks about practices,
immunities, and connections and meld
with ideas of social control.
Invocations have to be made.
Invocations constitute
an entire library,
offerings, compressing food.
I identify with specific datas.
As [inaudible] and
snails for [inaudible] god
and a definitive [inaudible] go
with his definition of metals.
Dress, dances, literature,
performance, drama.
[Inaudible] which I'm using
because of [inaudible]
was popularize [inaudible]
and without [inaudible]
won the Nobel prize.
That's the basis of his
Nobel, the god of iron.
That's where he draws
his ideas from.
Take [inaudible] for instance,
and the god lists you to chants,
elaborated [inaudible] chants
that you hear from [inaudible]
to the borders of [inaudible]
tries to dancing, to folklore,
to literature, to [inaudible],
to decorations
or [inaudible] combat
land with water,
humans with fish and crocodiles.
Crocodiles are our neighbors.
Fish, they are part of our neighbors
in the way these archives
are constituted.
You are not supposed to be
using their skin for decoration.
It's like killing your neighbors.
These are ideas that would
change their meanings
because of the way we
change the epistemologies.
[Inaudible] with productivity,
adding to the storehouse
of knowledge on woman and gender,
we can demonstrate this richness
in so many ways, making
use of gods and goddesses.
As we rework the complexities around
the datas to modern disciplines,
which we have to do, we have
[inaudible] get the ritual archives
into many component units,
as literature, music, drama,
psychology, and topology,
and many more.
And you and I walk
around each component
so that its scholar has studied
far in various departments.
Philosophy, music, drama,
literature, linguistics.
In each of these disciplines
[inaudible] becomes disconnected
from the modern layout
and intricately connected indigenous
epistemology that produces it.
In favor of the concerns
of the disciplines,
frame from all the epistemologies
is turn out to be indigenous.
Because all we are doing is
[inaudible] to start with.
In this regard [inaudible] has
been disembodied and fragmented.
The questions posed can become
external to [inaudible] make up.
For example, why do
you pose a question?
What advice a philosophy
or a religion?
It's you who's posing the question.
Incantation's magical tests
or creative literary test,
if our verses originally
recited [inaudible] what happens
when they become printed tests?
You can translate many of them.
Through the printed tests
[inaudible] do they become
as effective as divination?
I can give you an example
of an incantation,
but once I translate
it, it loses its power.
It's gone.
Tests as in the case of chance,
taken out of the [inaudible]
at entry points to the understanding
of history, to epistemologies
of cosmology and metrology.
But the cosmology and metrology
cannot operate without forms
of rationality, and they
need to explain other issues,
such as medicine, politics,
and critical [inaudible].
I'll be skipping many pages.
If you are interested in the
paper, it's already fully written.
It's 54 pages, and I'll be
willing to send it to you.
Space will not permit me
to elaborate on the breadth
of these archives or the density of
each of them, which is [inaudible]
that fragments, and [inaudible]
of individual constructions
and presentation.
Instead, I would like to take
some organic matters and objects,
some of which I brought with me to
illustrate what I'm talking about.
And some of them may
look so ordinary to you.
Let me start with what, if you have
been to Brazil or Bayah or Cuba,
it is one of the most common
objects you are going to find.
It's [inaudible] which is
mistranslated [inaudible].
It's call [inaudible].
You find it wherever
you find [inaudible] the
Atlantic [inaudible].
That plant alone, if you go to, you
can't go to Candombles, Santeria,
and all of them, without
confronting it.
It's -- it looks to you like
a small plant or [inaudible]
or [inaudible] photographs, test
ties, paintings and sculptures,
all like terms of religious
significance, but they are tests
that you can accumulate into
rich archives, and they speak
to a wide variety of issues.
And these tests are so many, and
for those of you who do literature,
you may have come across
them in this interest of time
and passing a number
of these things around
[ Inaudible Comment ]
They look ordinary
to you, but they open
up enormous amount of libraries.
Enormous. You have great things
fall apart, you will have come
across [inaudible] and what that
means in terms of significance.
These objects that I'm sharing
with you, they reach Cuba, Brazil,
United States and other areas, to
form part of the ritual archives
in the Afro-Atlantic religions.
On the African side, spirituality
and [inaudible] reality are united
as in the use of sculpture
to represent the datas.
So, for instance, this is
not an object of embroidery.
This is connected to the
complexity of divination
in which the [inaudible] and he uses
it to communicate so many things.
And for those of you
who have also gone
to Brazil [inaudible] you will see
the importance and have done it
in so many ways [inaudible]
in so many ways.
And during question and answer
time, I can talk about this
and you will see how this in
itself is like saying you want
to write a book [inaudible]
it is an object.
The [inaudible] were represented by
[inaudible] dance before authors bow
and arrow symbolized in
various forms of origin.
Objects peak and they
communicate with our worlds,
where people will do
[inaudible] will do silences,
because they are talking.
They're using a different language.
They're speaking to you, and
they're supplying narratives
that encourage the
creativity of storytelling
and the fascinated performance.
And then they use of such
objects as costumes, ritual trees,
woodcarvings, metal
sculpture, carvings [inaudible].
Ritual special has
become ritual performance,
and they not only become librarians.
They also are narrators.
They manipulate objects.
Some [inaudible] stories
will follow,
and they present ritual performances
before an audience to participate.
Objects encode the [inaudible]
of the being they represent,
even telling us they are
[inaudible] they are [inaudible].
Whether they are [inaudible]
cool and calm all the time,
colors are very significant.
And when [inaudible] African,
pay attention to color,
because they are talking to you.
They are denotative, as in
red, for being aggressive,
quick-tempered, white
for what it means.
And these colors average
on variations,
as in blue among the [inaudible].
In the contrasts [inaudible] binary
epistemology that leads to a series
of long conversations
on human behavior
and interpersonal relationships
in society,
the extensive poetry does work
with words in relation to objects.
Yielding methodologies and
epistemologies in the realm
of the [inaudible] historical
and institutions that lead us
to [inaudible] of knowing
and forms of knowledge.
The mistake we've made and why
Africans made this mistake is
to accept the notion of the museum.
That is a big mistake.
Because, when you treat
them as museum pieces,
with short descriptions
to describe them,
we've undermined them in many ways.
But if we have treated
them as archival items,
we will have acquired a
different form of results.
Yet these objects actually fit
into the description of an archive
as a place to keep
historical records.
Although the collection of certain
objects may defy categorization
because it means we have to work out
alternative sets of categorization,
the [inaudible] that I'm spreading
around, historical records.
The location of an archive may
be characterized as an archive
in itself, as in the groove of the
ritual tree, there are so many.
Where the tree and its
location constitute a library,
documents in an archive are
treated as primary sources,
so [inaudible] many ritual
objects be treated as such,
as they communicate messages that
can be used to reconstruct the past
and understand ideas
about the world.
Objects open a wide door to a large
body of methodologies, stories,
legends [inaudible] short and long.
And these categories are many.
Some, like written records
created for specific meaning,
that we communicate from
one person to another.
Some are signed as [inaudible]
among the [inaudible]
in which the combination of
powers in relation to [inaudible]
and other objects,
formulate extensive codes.
And you need special
ways to decode them
and to create test
and interpretations.
Ritual communications
while elaborate
from [inaudible] among
the [inaudible]
to the interpretation
of dreams and many more.
Objects represent [inaudible]
archives, like cemeteries,
a ground of memory, sacred
groves, and so many examples
that we have been able to ignore.
And in those examples, you see
how we work into us, spirits.
Humans and theories are
united in ways of knowing
that [inaudible] secularization
in academic programs,
as some students engage with the
belief that witches are with them
in their classrooms,
thus leading them
to the generation of
nonwestern ideas.
They supply test on the environment
and open us to multiple worlds
of charms, magic, and medicine.
Songs are constructed,
derived from them.
Based on sound observation of
various uses for curing diseases.
The [inaudible] that I've just
prayed around is part of the species
that is common, useful for food, but
also for its medicinal properties,
from its connections with diabetes,
to the reduction of headaches
and fever [inaudible]
with AIDS, as well.
The Brazilian species has multiple
uses [inaudible] and antibacterial.
Plans are part of our
knowledge system.
Certain plans entangle a
world with those of nonhumans.
In this entanglement, facts
and fiction become mashed
into both complex and simple ideas,
and we try to unite
them in various ways.
They supply ideas of prayers
and philosophy, as in the case
of [inaudible] and
images and sculpture
and paintings are abundant,
where there are connections
with historical writings
and with what we call,
are characterizing
various departments,
we need to rethink them
and strengthen them.
We tend to use more as book
covers, the sculpture and paintings,
than as elaborate tests
within the books.
[Inaudible] images of
philosophical expressions,
connected with thought and life.
Look at televisions.
We tend to see and appreciate them,
not necessarily engage
in dialogue with them.
However, images represent
mentalities, power, and strength.
They come used to generate
image theories
and create extensive
narratives on cultures,
transcultures, and intercultures.
They supply critically [inaudible].
To carve an object is
about the representation
of self, history, identity.
One image of issue, which happens
to be one of my favorite thoughts,
tell us about social and cultural
issues, portray of multiple
and ambivalent ideas, represent
[inaudible] of [inaudible].
This [inaudible] difference,
perception, semiotics, religion.
Multiple specializations can
emerge around image theory,
image [inaudible] methodologies,
image anthropology,
image and culture, image
philosophy, perception on singing,
listening, silences, image styling.
An image moves you
towards virtual images,
but it's an aesthetic idea living
within that image, alive with test
and cultures, forms and styles.
While gazing without talking,
you create the test on your own,
saying something, creating
what [inaudible] calls an omni
of metaphors.
It generates a wide range of
imaginations and tough systems.
To take [inaudible]
image, like the ambiguity
of [inaudible] it cannot be ready
in an interpretive singularity.
[Inaudible] ideas within itself
and ideas outside of itself.
Same, they may use to see
force and strength, power.
Epistemic responses that
connect back to language
and metaphysical perceptions.
[Inaudible] about the body, in its
physical and nonphysical realms.
An element in the body
[inaudible] and yet another
to the assumptions
of transgressions.
The politics of images lead us
to the pregnancy of culture,
ready to give birth
to social issues.
In a sense [inaudible]
you move to the realm
of beauty [inaudible] conversation
on every day practices, languages,
what creation, forceful
inscription of perception
and experience onto
our consciousness.
Look further, and in the issue
image enforce more dimensions
around performance and other bodies
of knowledge [inaudible]
and other ideas.
The thought that you express
to yourself and to others,
we move you back to the issue image.
Its force becomes a part of you.
Whether you aide or like issue,
the image becomes activated.
In the process, you must
generate test around the image,
expressing your religiosity,
philosophy, and opinions.
Issue has entered your
mental system.
Actually, via conversation and
with others, your thought is a test
on the physical world,
on the afterlife,
on metrologies, on
religion, and more.
And your test is going to be
different from my own test.
An artistic production becomes a
body of knowledge at various levels.
Political, cultural, social.
The issue image transfers you
to the understanding
of culture and society.
What is left of the past and how the
past is sort of formed, deformed,
[inaudible] all that
and read all that.
The past may even be disappearing
and that image advances.
[Inaudible] originally appears
by this small wooden object
opens a vastness of knowledge.
Its edges become borderless.
Its assistance requires a force.
We are no longer dealing with
the aesthetic of difference,
as in looking at objects in the
British museum in London and looking
at issue in the Republic of Benin.
We are first to move into
the objects of knowledge,
in which all component parts
of the body become signifiers
of [inaudible] issue.
Becomes different.
A human's face [inaudible] all the
components are breaking them down,
and this unit is semiautonomous,
but aggregated to [inaudible] issue
in [inaudible] of meaning.
Had their issue recitation,
you create [inaudible]
like your own head [inaudible].
That of issues also [inaudible]
of intelligence and emotions.
All this calculations and
miscalculations reside here.
You can see his head.
You can see his body,
his frowns, attributes.
Then derive from various parts
of these components of the body,
all concerned with
[inaudible] and destiny.
You have to trick your own
wisdom and strength to deal
with [inaudible] issue,
and as you do so,
your own thinking process will
begin to break down into a series
of components, as that of your
own wisdom of your own stupidity.
You draw in your own [inaudible]
knowledge from your stomach,
because in some cultures,
you put knowledge
in your stomach, not just food.
To rely on your inner senses,
your eyes must work well
to recall your inner
essence and your perception.
So, you become confused,
you have to seek wisdom
and fully elaborate conversation.
And inside derived from your
stomach, you become the point
of validation and you can
create insets of knowledge.
The issue image, coupled with all
of the objects as well as all tests,
and the entire ritual archives,
leads us to the indigenous
intellectuals
and their epistemologies.
Combined, they deal with
invisible realities of knowledge,
as in witchcraft, while they
complicate the visible ones,
as in all forms of epistemologies,
and of a long section
on epistemologies and how, if you
are able to use these archives,
we will no longer be talking about
universalism, what about [inaudible]
in which separate epistemologies
that derive
from the [inaudible] archives
will lead us to fresh ideas.
And this is going to be a
bigger project in which we begin
to understand indigenous
knowledge systems, the [inaudible]
of the entire range of
vernacular epistemologies
into formal education system, and
we begin to teach a new generation
of students a new body of ideas.
The connection between
[inaudible] power
and [inaudible] knowledge
is very clear-cut,
and how [inaudible] knowledge has
been problematic in a continent
like Africa, and part of the ways
in which we can challenge
this knowledge is
to rethink not just
the archives we use,
but to search for the very same
test of the epistemologies.
And these epistemologies are many,
and we have not started
the work we need to do.
Let me now go to the
last part, which is,
how do we move these archives
into the public spaces?
Because we have to do them, we have
to move them into public spaces.
Whether it's tests,
objects, or symbols,
ritual archives are face serious
dangers, ranging from extinction,
ridicule, marginalization,
and [inaudible].
The first problem is that
of intellectual inequality.
All externally derived knowledge
systems, Islamic and western,
are seen to be superior to them.
The inability to create permanent
written text with specialists linked
to formal system of
knowledge, as in the case
of western derived
academies, create a drawback.
The social contest of
knowledge production is crucial
and is [inaudible] of trouble.
Africans scholars who
produce knowledge
for Africa's [inaudible] instead
of fully embracing these
ancestral epistemologies.
What should we do?
I want to make five recommendations.
First, that we must modify the
orientation of our research
and that [inaudible] scholars as
researchers and [inaudible] side
of it, should be integrated
in a different manner.
That the [inaudible] that we have
created is forced and we have
to bring back indigenous ways
of knowing into what we do.
We have to rethink the outcome
of our research, the assumption
that the research [inaudible] is the
most important is very misleading.
Indeed, indigenous
researchers connect
with the organic communities more
directly, feeding the constitution
of knowledge and ways of knowing.
We have to assume that the power
of social agency does not just lie
in the academy and we must
give social agency to those
who produce other forms
of knowledge.
We have to rethink how we
produce knowledge and have
to ask the question,
"Who are we, anyway?"
We're right about the
sociology of knowledge.
Not necessarily by building
on indigenous inheritances
or by operating indigenous voices
into a chaotic [inaudible].
We write about the
sociology of social movements.
Without joining the working
class to protest injustice.
We write about gods and goddesses.
Why not join in their worship?
Is it that observe us.
We disconnect what we drew
from the public that we serve.
We must begin to locate
the communities compel
and update catalogs.
Ritual archives already exist in
private spaces with associations,
organized [inaudible] and we
have to connect more with them.
We must begin to encourage
autobiographies, [inaudible]
and religious [inaudible] and we
must begin to keep them in ways
that assessable to others.
We have to begin the process of
digitizing them, given the fact
that this is not possible.
I'm calling for the
reconfiguration of disciplines.
Saying that the colonial
structure of the old
and very new universities
has not been very hospitable
for this form of archives.
We must begin to allow
[inaudible] to be reaching
with a new set of substance.
And even to be written in
indigenous African languages.
And the academy has
to accept the validity
of the use African languages
as well as the validity of many
of these new and alternative
sources.
And by doing so, the tourists
will [inaudible] will be many.
I want to read my last paragraph
and I want to start with a proverb.
"A person who carries
a basket of eggs
on his head must walk
with measured steps."
In the final analysis, perhaps you
and I as practitioners
operating the western academies,
will become the traditional
intellectuals whose power
and legitimacy will be
challenged and superseded
by organic intellectuals
connected with this organic data.
And organic intellectuals
whose legitimacy will be based
on epistemologies derived
from ritual archives.
As well as intellectual rationality
build around cultural legitimacy.
They have to rethink what we have
inherited, and rethinking them,
they may move us forward
in new ways.
We cannot continue to
carry baskets of eggs
on our heads and be
walking in haste.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Angel Batiste: Thank
you, Dr. Falola.
I think you've certainly given the
African studies field a challenge.
But when we look at the
African world, the importance
of indigenous knowledge
becomes very, very critical.
At this point, we can open up
for a very short Q and A. So,
if we have anyone who would
like to pose a question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Toyin Falola: Okay,
I understand now.
I can't take many questions
so I can answer them.
>> Angel Batiste: Okay.
We'll take all the questions and
then Doctor Falola will answer.
Cybal, would you like to?
>> Doctor Falola, I'd like to thank
you so much for your presentation.
It brings back memories to
me, because I too am a regular
at the University of [inaudible].
While I was there, I was mentored
by Professor [inaudible] -
>> Toyin Falola: Of blessed memory.
>> Student: You mentioned
around him.
I understand what you're saying.
I'd like you to clarify, what was it
when you said that the distinction
of difference between
[inaudible] and history?
Because as I know it,
[inaudible] is history.
So just clarify what constitutes
[inaudible] makes it different
from history.
>> Angel Batiste: Okay.
We have a question here.
Would you like to go
on with your question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Joanne: Would you
like to go over it?
>> Toyin Falola: Yes, yes.
Joanne, you have to ask me a
question, I won't let you go.
[inaudible] for you.
>> Joanne: Thank you so
much for your presentation.
>> Toyin Falola: Yeah.
>> Student: First of
all [inaudible] Falola.
My question is, though [inaudible]
African languages documenting the
statue era of report.
[inaudible] Are you particular
about African institutions
or the United States?
That is one part of it.
My other question is, how is it with
[inaudible] with use African beliefs
to write a report [inaudible]
participants [inaudible] Africa?
>> Toyin Falola: Okay.
I want to answer all the questions.
>> Angel Batiste: Okay.
let's take one last --
the two last questions
and then we'll let the
professor answer or respond.
>> Student: So [inaudible] the
opportunity to [inaudible].
For those of us in diaspora who are
part of the descendent community.
We come seeking knowledge
that is our inheritance.
Some of it we can get through books.
We don't have access to the
oral tradition in the same way.
I once asked Dr. [inaudible]
about the way we,
children in the diaspora
understand things.
And he told me that
sometimes the ancestors talk
to the children in our dreams.
And I'm wondering if you
might talk about that.
>> Toyin Falola: Yes, ma'am.
>> Student: [Inaudible] can you
just tell us the ritual [inaudible]
>> Toyin Falola: Well, I don't think
you can have the time to do that.
What are all the ways [inaudible]
because what I was trying to say is
that they're very elaborate.
They just don't mean one
thing and also be in mind,
and objective operates in multiple
ways in terms of combination.
So, this [inaudible]
and turned them around
and combined them differently.
That's the way objects work.
So, they don't lend themselves to
just singularity of interpretations.
So, and then when you -- so, when
you take this one, for instance,
it gets connected to
rites of passage.
And as a change of rites of passage,
this one changes its meaning
and it opens up a great
amount of conversation.
So, I drew this as
an interpretation.
If I drew this is that
interpretation?
If I break it, I'm saying
something different.
Then I begin to chew it.
I'm changing this minute.
So, the point I'm trying to make,
and I tried to use this shoe
as an example, is to say that, you
see, I tried to use the analogies
that people can relate to
tests, tests, tests, or library
and library, because
it's a knowledge system
that begins to talk.
I can use this to pray that God
is going to give you long life.
I even had incantations.
I changed the meaning.
It become something else, so
I will talk more one on one.
The language questions has
always come up forever.
It will always come up.
So, there are countries
on the ten million.
There are actually
countries six million people
who use their language.
Czech Republic, Sweden,
the state of Israel.
[inaudible] you asked
me the question.
Are you there?
They use their language to
[inaudible] for instance, right?
They are bigger than all these
countries that I just mentioned.
And there's a dozen countries,
there's just ten million
people who use their language.
Or valley of the development
of Hebrew language [inaudible].
For the best example the
Africana in South Africa.
They were so successful.
That's -- I do not know
[inaudible] African [inaudible] used
until current challenges.
They created this language in South
Africa, they insisted on using it.
Part of what led to the
Soviet uprising for those
of you who are alive then.
Was because they want
to impose Africana.
And sold it to black people
and it led to a major crisis.
So, it's actually not true that you
cannot take a language and turn it
into a academic project
or use it in school.
One of the projects that was averted
was [inaudible] she mentioned
in which we actually started this.
[inaudible] language of
education from elementary school.
Who started it?
And it worked.
Unfortunately today,
you now have Africans
who cannot speak African languages.
You have [inaudible] who
cannot use the language.
The tragedy is they are
not good in English either.
It's not that simply
a good [inaudible].
And if you look at [inaudible]
like [inaudible] well,
it is the grand [inaudible]
language that makes a Chevy.
If you take off the Hebrew
language from there, what is --
what are you going to have?
So, the tremendous advantages that
are located in this language, right?
We begin to lose it by the, so I
don't like to use myself an example.
When I wrote my memoirs,
two of them in French,
I wrote it in what you would
call [inaudible] English.
They could not find a copy
editor, it's not going to work.
And the publisher said, "And
it became very successful.
Okay, okay.
We will not dub your English."
And each [inaudible] the
memoir they asked me questions.
There's a line I started by
saying, "A frog would not know
that there are two worlds
unless it jumps into hot water."
A student comes to me and said, "Why
would a frog jumps into hot water?
Is it stupid?"
But as a language, if I say, what
is after six is more than seven.
Nobody in England can say that
because it's not possible for him
or for her to ever think that way.
What is six after seven, is
an organic way of talking
and it's connected to
a specific location.
And what is after six after seven,
as small as it is, is a conversation
that you and I can stay here
until tomorrow to be discussing.
You can actually, in
Africa universities,
write [inaudible] in [inaudible].
That is within your
reparations to formulate.
You don't need any stand-up
power to validate it.
It wasn't like the time when
I was drinking sea level.
That they had to take my
scripts to the west of London.
That moment is gone
because they now,
they can't be blaming
thing on other people.
They [inaudible] of themselves and
say, "We want you to write your PhD
in [inaudible] of Nigeria
in [inaudible]."
Nobody can stop them.
They are the one validating
that degree and making use of it
within the national boundaries.
And they'll be surprised that
that person can work elsewhere.
So, I think we've been very
careless in that regard.
Generally, we have been
very careless and we have
to rethink the very process.
You can -- the very fact that you
use your languages as a [inaudible]
in Germany or in France does not
mean don't assess other languages.
I'm actually much better in
[inaudible] than in English
because that was my generation,
that's how we went to school.
And then at some point my
grandmother also forced me
to learn Arabic.
So, this language issue is a project
of state policy and it's one we have
to seriously think about.
The first question, yes, yes.
Can you begin to demystify
this object over time?
That's what morality and western
science will move you towards.
But be in mind that those who plan
education system for you and those
who shape the knowledge system
can also create agencies
in the other direction.
You know they can do that.
And what they say.
When I was at the age of ten,
I quoted all the classics
in [inaudible].
Indeed, I wrote my first
play at the age of 12.
Why? Because the set of this
elaborate drama competition,
[inaudible] competition
across a big region.
And they were asking us to
compete and we're competing.
That's how my interest in language
and performances developed.
Years later, when I wrote a play and
I was looking for people to act it,
I was shocked that getting
people to act was very difficult.
You know why?
Because they are not -- they are
no longer organically connected
to acting as a day to day
practice as I was as a child.
In which, that play that we are
doing was what we later learned
in the U.S. it will be performance.
I come from Ibadan, and if you have
been to it you will know Ibadan.
You cannot live in my city
without an extensive
infrastructure of language.
And we pride ourselves
in the ability
to create instant poems
to abuse people.
You just have to master
it, you just have
to master it and it's
very intricate.
And as you begin to do that, by the
time anybody sets up a chair there,
you already have people that are
already so brilliant and so good
in acting that you don't have to be
spending so much time training them.
And you see how Nollywood, which
is the third largest movie industry
in the world, is bringing
back some of these things.
Bringing back some of these things.
We -- I think it's
tragic to lose them.
It's very tragic.
[inaudible] history in the
western academy follows a
formative definition.
So, which we give a degree
and that formal definition,
it will say that the
definition of [inaudible].
First of all, any project of
translation is very risky.
If I say [inaudible] you
are making a big mistake.
It doesn't work like that.
If I say character and you say
[inaudible], if I say head.
So, projects of translations are
very problematic because a component
of what [inaudible] will call
[inaudible] is much broader
than what we call history
to every university degree.
Because when you break it down, it's
called chains metaphysical world.
The environment, they
don't separate them.
Trees and human beings
can be living together.
Stories of the elephants and
human beings can be combined
and they combine them with issues
of memory and issues of [inaudible].
So, the way they define
it, you have to fracture it
into various disciplines
because it's not just history,
it'll include connectings
that we're now starting.
And finally, your dreams and
what that you all told you, well,
we have to keep dreaming.
She's been asking me to
stop and I will wait behind
and check more questions.
>> Angel Batiste: I'm sorry
that we have to end our program
at this point, but
again, please join me
in thanking Dr. Falola
for his presentation.
I'd also like to invite
you in our conference room.
We have a small display of some
of the works of Dr. Falola,
so please join us in
the conference room
and perhaps we can continue
conversations there.
Thank you.
>> Automated: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as L-O-C dot gov.